[MUSIC]
Good morning, good afternoon,
good evening,
wherever you might be
joining us from today.
My name is Elisa Keppl,
I'm a member of the MBA admissions
team here at the Stanford GSB.
I want to thank all of you for
joining us today for
this session called Your Journey.
Now, I know from women leaders.
We are going to have a wonderful panel but
first I wanted to talk a little
bit about our global community and
specifically, the community of women.
That both come to the GSB and are now out
in the world as alumni of the program.
I will ask some questions
to our panelists, so
that they can start sharing
their experiences, and
start sharing their insights,
about their time at the Stanford GSB.
But this session is also for you.
So, not only do we want to hear who you
are, and where you're calling in from,
in the Q&A pod, but feel free throughout
the session, to ask questions in that too.
For all of you joining today, you'll
have the chance to upvote a question.
So if someone asks something that
you also want to hear the answer too
don't feel the need to
ask the question again.
You can just vote a thumbs up, and
it'll help raise that question to the top,
and we'll try to get to
as many as we can today.
And so with that, the GSB alumni, you'll
hear the term you're joining the GSB
family when you come to the Stanford
family and when you come to the GSB.
That holds very true and hopefully you'll
hear perspectives about that from our
panelists today, but the alumni
community has 30,000 plus strong.
They're 60 volunteer led regional
chapters that are around the world.
So even just getting a sense of
where you're calling in from.
Today is really a great representation of
just Is the global nature of the program.
Specific to women, there are women's
programs, there's obviously a club on
campus that supports women through
their journey during their time.
At the GSB but also upon graduation,
there are numerous resources for women.
And one of the more well known programs
that you might hear about something called
Women Circle.
I'm not sure if any of our panelists
are involved in those, but if so,
we'd love to hear about
your experience in that.
And then there's also as alumni of the
program support from our career services
and other learning
programs available to you.
As you continue to grow
throughout your career post GSB.
So today we have our panelists joining us.
I'd like to have them
introduce themselves.
So I have information on
each of them up here, but
I will actually ask each of them to
specifically introduce themselves.
And then as they introduce themselves so
you can share kind of what you were doing
before the GSB and where you are now.
But I'd also love for each of you to share
what was your most memorable experience
during your time at the GSB?
So this could be a class that you took,
it could be a trip that you took anything
that comes to mind when I say what really
impacted you during your time at the GSB.
What's your top Memory?
So with that, Onik,
would you be willing to start?
>> Sure.
Hi, my name is Onika.
>> Onika sorry.
[LAUGH]
>> All right,
I graduated from the GSB in 2012.
So, you wanted sort of a short intro and
the
>> Yeah, short intro and
then if you can share what was
>> What kind of most impactful or
memorable for you?
That would be great.
>> Yeah, of course,
I came to the GSB from consulting,
had done some
entrepreneurship on the side.
And since the GSB have mostly been a tech
startups, I did a small stint at google,
but otherwise have been in sort of
seed stage, through Series B,
Series c startups.
I've been the CIO at the last To you, and
currently now I am at stripe
working on new products for
startups where I used
to be the customer for
this kind of product.
And gosh,
probably one of the things that's
most memorable to me from the GSB
was actually my WIM group,
My women in management
group May not have waltzed
into your life under other circumstances.
And I really treasure some of
those relationships today.
>> Awesome, thanks for sharing.
Tamer, why don't you go next?
>> Hi everyone?
I'm Tamer I'm so excited to be here.
I like absolutely loved my GSB
experience so definitely pumped to talk
to you all about it especially
like the perspective as a woman.
So my background was in technology and
media before school.
I worked at YouTube in the Bay Area.
As the Content Strategy Team there,
my team was responsible for
writing the Help Center.
We worked with creators on their
monetization, like strategies and so
I did mostly partnerships.
Now I'm at Netflix.
I'm also on the Content Strategy Team,
but it's vastly different.
It's much more like a finance and
strategic role.
And we focus on what are the valuations
for the shows that we're putting on what
are the competitive intelligence what's
going on like in the world around us.
As well as just like what types of
shows we should renew and cancel and
what we should be making.
I work on reality TV,
which I watched all the time.
Anyway, we forgot to Netflix that we have
Questions about bling Empire selling
sunset nail it, that's why we're gone.
And I have so
many great memories from the GSB but
I think probably my favorites were
all the travel that I got to do.
I was really choosing between Stanford and
another program where I would have been
able to do a dual master's degree and
learn more French and
like spend a lot of time in Africa.
And so I've made it a goal of mine to go
to Africa as much as possible while I was
at the GSB.
I was able to visit I think,
nine African countries and
the two years I was here which is insane.
And my favorite was Probably my G mix,
which was in Togo, I worked for
the government of Togo and West Africa.
I spoke French there and
I worked on their incubator strategy for
startups in the region,
especially thinking about agrotech and
like how they can make a better incubator.
And so that was just Insane and
not an opportunity I would have had had I
not gone to the GSB to like literally work
at the top like government even see
working on startups in West Africa.
So that was my favorite among many
other trips Africa that I went on.
>> That's awesome.
Thank you for sharing that.
sithara Why don't we
go to you next Loved it
basically worked with
the impact investors to
scale up social services and
local communities.
So did that for
a few years before the GSB.
And then came into the GSB kind of sort
of undecided on what I wanted to do.
Explored a couple of different
industries my first year there.
I nded up really liking a lot of kind of
a social impact focus of healthcare but
feeling like I had flexibility to
build a career both in the private and
the public sector.
So post GSB I now work at bright health,
which is a company
that's about five years old,
has grown really rapidly and
kind of offers health plans
on the ACA exchanges.
And my most memorable experience of
the GSB I feel like it's hard to pick
I think one experience that really stands
out to me was If your friends and I lead
a global study trip our second year, which
is something second year students do, and
all of us had had grown up in the Midwest,
so we decided to lead a global study trip.
That was basically five minivans
driving through the Midwest.
We started in Pittsburgh,
we ended up in Chicago.
We got to meet with the CEO of
US Steel as well as the head of
Uber self driving car unit.
We met Dan Gilbert,
who founded Quicken mortgage loans and
now also owns the Cleveland Cavaliers.
I had the joy of trying to get
him to stop talking an hour and
a half into our meeting,
[LAUGH] which I think is the first and
only time I'll have tried to
get a billionaire to shut up.
[LAUGH] And,
we kind of ended our trip in Chicago,
we got to meet kind of Pete Budaj Edge.
really got to introduce some of
my classmates who were from so
many different countries, so
many parts of the United States to a part
of the country that I really love.
And it was just really thoughtful,
wonderful trip with a really
good group of people.
>> Awesome thanks for
sharing before we go to Heather next and
I see that a Areeba join so
thank you so much for joining.
It's nice to see you.
I do want to just for those on the call
you've heard a couple acronyms thrown out
G mix and then you heard Global Study Trip
mentioned which is for short called GST.
These are different ways in which
you can fulfill another acronym,
which is your GER your
Global Experience Requirement.
So a big part of the Stanford program is
encouraging you to go out of your comfort
zone and one of the ways in which that can
be encouraged is to require that you spend
time in a place that you have never
lived in or worked in before.
And that is your global
experience requirement.
It can be fulfilled by doing a GST or
doing a G mix.
So you've heard both of those mentioned
and then as you also heard just now you
can also lead a Global Study Trip
in your second year.
So i just want everyone on the call to
understand what's being talked about.
You'll hear just a large number of
acronyms as [LAUGH] we start talking
about the Stanford GSB.
So Heather, why don't we go
next to introduce yourself and
share your most impactful time and
then Areeba, we'll go to you next.
>> Okay, hi everybody.
My name is Heather.
I was the class of 2020 with Tamar.
Before coming to Stanford,
I worked as a consultant at
Deloitte Consulting in Chicago.
And then I came because I wasn't
really sure what I wanted to do next.
So I did something totally different for
my summer between my two years and I went
and works at Rothy's, which makes shoes
out of recycled plastic water bottles.
I did product strategy for them and
it was a really awesome time.
But then ultimately, another hard pivot in
my second year, I ended up taking a class
called startup garage, which is kind
of a hands on learning experience.
And out of that class, my co-founder and
I actually did start the company that
we started as a part of that class.
Called frankly apparel and
we make brawlers clothing so perfect for
your pandemic wear needs.
So that's kind of that's what I've been
doing for the last year and a half.
I'm based in Chicago we do
almost everything remotely, but
we produce in Los Angeles.
And then my most memorable experience of
the GSB kind of like everybody said it.
There's so many like little moments and
memories with friends and
the connections you form.
But I think also a little closer to home,
one would be definitely the the startup
garage class because it totally impacted
what I did after I left school.
And one of our professors actually ended
up being an investor in our company.
So it really like made a huge impact
on kind of where I went with my future.
And then the second would be
my time as an Arbuckle fellow.
That's a leadership program that you
can do your second year where you help
guide first year through a portion
of their core curriculum.
And you're really learning like
leadership and management skills.
Really hands on, and as part of that you
get to take interpersonal dynamics or
touchy feely a little bit earlier.
You take it your first year.
Taking that class our first year and
then having an entire year to practice it
with people that kind of spoke the same
language and we're in the same mindset.
Changed so much about how I
communicate in all aspects of my life,
professional, personal everything.
So those have had a really
lasting impact on who I am and
how I show up in in the world, yeah.
>> Awesome, thanks for sharing.
And Areeba, we'll have you go next.
Again, just introducing yourself and
then sharing what
is your most impactful memory or
experience that you had at the GSB.
You're representing our most
recent graduating class so
it'll be great to hear your perspective.
>> Thanks Alisa, my name is Areeba.
And welcome to all of the folks
joining this call and
all of you who are here to present and
to be on the panel with you.
I grew up in Pakistan has lived in
the States for about nine years, almost
exactly actually yesterday was my nine
year anniversary of emigrating by myself.
And God Allah alumni here it's super
exciting to be on the panel with you.
Yesterday was my nine year
anniversary of emigrating by myself.
[LAUGH] I celebrated it with a picnic
in the park in San Francisco with a lot
of my GSB friends.
And I worked in consulting before
the GSB and I'm right now in
a conference room at Apple park where
I am the lead product manager for
all their accessibility features
across all their devices.
Still learning all the things
that that that entails.
And super excited about
the opportunity and
could not have gotten here
without the folks at the GSB.
And I think my favorite memory of the GSB,
I'm going to cheat and
choose a team rather than a memory.
And that has to do with writing and
speaking.
I work in finance and
now work in technology.
And if I had to just pick my dream career
would have been a writer or a journalist.
I'm the daughter of a writer and
didn't always have the luxury
of thinking about humanities or
arts just because of visa constraints and
financial responsibilities.
It just was much easier to work
in consulting or writing deck.
But the GSB gave me
a look at what it means
to just continue writing and speaking.
And living my life with words
outside of directly career paths and
so did some called Lukino which stands for
Lives Organizations and
world, the LOW in there.
You can look up Lukinos on YouTube.
There's a whole series of them and every
year, somewhere around 20 GSB students
give a Lukino on on a team
that they really care about.
And I got to give again a talk on what it
means to integrate grief into your life.
I lost a parent while I was at the GSB.
And the experience of dealing with
that and of studying grief and
its impact on like human psychology,
and just just your life, and
what we get wrong about it, and
what we get right about it, and
putting that in the context of a pandemic.
Just being able to put an academic
structure around something as personal as
grief was really empowering for me.
And being able to give a talk on that in
the middle of a pandemic that goes on
the GSB YouTube was
incredibly powerful also.
I also encourage everyone here
to look at a nondisclosure.
It's the GSB magazine you can find it on
medium and it's accessible to everyone and
I got to work with
really awesome folks and
just writing pieces for
the GSB magazine called nondisclosure.
So for instance, be advocated for
making all clubs at the GSB completely
duties free and that was something that I
got to reply with a coursemate I wrote
something on just body image and
eating disorders and what that means in
terms of being a professional woman and
navigating all sorts of body politics and
the role of gender in that.
And that was another thing that I
got to do it for the GSB magazine,
completely unrelated to any three but
related to career but not directly.
Yeah, so non disclosure, low key notes,
do awesome things to check out and
do my favorite experiences.
Yeah, they're just opportunities every
single day to speak up in classes.
And for those of you who are not
familiar with it already,
the GSB doc is another amazing
experience that I got to partake in.
And folks typically do where every
Wednesday night you spend an hour
listening to two of your classmates
describe their journey through life.
And that spans all aspects of your life,
not just your career and the experience of
giving a talk but also listening to
classmates describe their lives and
their backgrounds every Wednesday night.
I'm was incredibly empowering.
And so I think the GSB is a place that
encourages you to bring all of yourself
into your career and
your social life and your personal life.
And it really teaches you how to
communicate all the things that
are important to you and
I really had a blast with that.
>> Awesome, thank you so much for sharing.
And those are all amazing things
to share with our audience today,
as all of you on this call
are learning more about the GSB.
And those are programs that,
as Areeba said,
do encourage you to bring your whole self.
And also a lot of them are mentioned
whether it's Arbuckle fellows or talk or
low keynote of just pushing you to
develop yourself as a leader and
understand who you are and
how you can Influence others.
So those are all just great examples.
Thank you so much.
So one of our most highest upvoted
questions is what I'm going to pose
next to all of you.
And this is obviously specific to the
theme today of just talking about being
a woman in business and a leader.
How do you think Stanford specifically?
And this could be something again,
specific to your time at Stanford or
even just obtaining an MBA from Stanford?
How has that prepared you as a leader,
specifically a female
leader in your career?
So I'm just going to start now
at the top of migrated on zoom.
[LAUGH] it says no specific order, but
Heather you're at the top of my grid.
So we'll start with you on this one.
>> Sure, perfect, female founding
team of a Female Centric Company.
I can definitely talk to this theme.
So a couple of things for me,
the first is that there are a few specific
classes at Stanford that are particularly
focused on female leadership.
And or women in leadership and
both of them to the to their
specifically women leadership.
They also have diverse leadership and
other types of classes
that encompass women.
But there are two that are specifically
focused on women in leadership positions
and one with Fern Mandelbaum and one
with Laurie Laura, Arriaga and Reessen.
They are different quarters, so
you can take both of them and
they have slightly different events.
And I actually found those
classes to be to be great,
because of all the amazing
female speakers that came in.
I'm great because of like the tactical
tools and exercises that you do.
But also primarily because it's a lot of
really strong, amazing women in the class
and this amazing female professor
who really cares about the women in.
And often you will get a few men and
it's I'm always so
thrilled when men join those
classes just for the record.
I think they bring a really
interesting perspective and
shows that they are interested in learning
about how 50% of the population is
impacted in their work.
I think it's really eye opening.
So, that was one way.
And then the other one I think was
really I came in coming from a pretty
male dominated field and consulting.
And I think I battled early in my career
before coming to GSB a lot of this
stereotypes associated with being
an assertive woman in the workplace,
especially a young, assertive woman and
late in the workplace.
And I was really struggling kind
of with my self concept and
how to stay true to my
personal leadership style, and
be an authentic leader, but
still be taken seriously.
And can tell you I'm a highly
emotional person and
I wear my emotions on my sleeve.
So I'm kind of trying to figure out
how to balance that in the workplace.
And all of these the opportunities
that I got to kind
of put my leadership skills to the test.
So through Arbuckle,
through interpersonal dynamics,
all of these classes helped me
become a lot more confident.
And how I was showing up and
then my specific brand of leadership
how to place in the workplace.
>> Awesome, thanks for sharing.
Anneke I know you already shared with us
in terms of your most memorable experience
being your time working
with women in management.
But if you have anything else to add,
we'd love to hear that in terms of
how it helped you in your career.
>> Yeah, for
sure when folks asked me what,
did you actually learn
anything in your MBA?
I always say that particularly I think
this is unique to the Stanford program,
my number one learning and
takeaway was that authentically sharing
vulnerability with other people is
the quickest way to build rapport.
And sort of like the kind of intimacy
that you need to do anything.
That's have a relationship,
build a company, lead a team,
all of those things come from
the authentic sharing of vulnerability.
Which is wait, what I feel like that
is not aligned with what most people
think an MBA program is about,
which is about sort of beating your chest.
And how can you be the next
Titan of industry?
And that was not at all my experience
at Stanford, from everything from
the curriculum, courses that have
already been described here in detail.
But talk, I think, is a great example,
women groups is a great example.
All of the ways that you build connections
with other people, and find ways to
continue to show up more vulnerably in
an authentic way, really, really helpful.
And that is something that has allowed
me I think to lean into my own style of,
sort of leadership as a woman, of bringing
that kind of vulnerability to the way
that I engage with my
team the way that I am.
Honest with my team,
in what I do and don't know.
The way that I'm honest with my
team when giving them feedback,
the way that I'm honest with my team,
if I messed at a startup and
things are failing, what do I tell them?
All of those things require you being able
to bring that sort of vulnerability, and
sort of confidence, right?
I think when you're not
bringing vulnerability,
it's sometimes about putting up errors.
And there's there's all kinds of negative
externalities that can come from that
which is, I think aligned with like a more
traditionally kind of maybe male way of
approaching business and decision making.
And so, while it is not exclusively about,
sort of being a woman or not,
I think that's something that's
been really helpful for me.
And something I've heard from a lot
of my female classmates as well.
>> Awesome, thanks.
Tamar, I have you next in my grid,
[LAUGH].
>> Yeah, I love this question.
I definitely agree with
everything that's been said.
And Heather, I love that you're emotional.
I think that something that I learned
from Stanford is that there's power in
difference.
No matter who you are, where you come
from, and to not show that part of
yourself is actually you're doing
a disservice to yourself into your team.
So, I've always been incredibly bubbly,
but
also I'm really happy
to ask tough questions.
And I realized in the first few weeks
at Stanford if there was a professor or
a guest that said something
that I disagreed with I
would immediately raise my hand and
ask a question.
Or say this is why I disagree.
And it was a little bit scary at first,
but
I realized that people saw
that as authentic leadership.
And even if they disagreed,
it was something that we can have
a conversation about afterward.
And it made me much more confident
to do that, not only in class but
in going forward.
I also think was a really important lesson
for me because even though the team I'm on
at Netflix has the same name as
the team I was on at YouTube,
they're completely different.
I'm working on finance and strategy,
which is something that I didn't actually
have experience in before
my internship at Netflix.
I was much more on the content side,
I majored in literature
when I was at Columbia.
I felt like I was a soft skill person.
And so, to know that there was power in my
difference, to know that if I showed up, I
look different, I speak different, I came
from Google, I'm going to wear different
things than people who are on my team who
mostly came from consulting and banking.
That's actually a huge plus for me.
People are going to remember me because
my name is completely different.
It's hard to pronounce.
I have to tell you again
how to pronounce it.
That means you remember it.
Yes, Anneke, I see you snuffing.
And then, also, just own that,
show up as that person.
And so, I see question about imposter
syndrome here, too, and I feel like that
goes into being a woman and learning how
to lead through, feeling like maybe I look
different, or I seem different, or the way
I talk is different than everyone here.
But, in fact,
I found that it was my greatest strength.
And the more that I leaned into it,
the more that I remember what
was said in my classes and
the better connections that I made with
people in and outside of my classes.
So that's absolutely something that
I've brought with me to Netflix.
And something that definitely makes
me stand out at Netflix, as well.
And I think that has made
me a much better worker.
And if I had tried or if I tried to be
a version of me that I am actually not,
I'm going to be unhappy and
my work is actually going to be worse than
if I'm just the real version of myself.
>> Awesome, thank you.
Sithara, I have you next,
if you want to answer that.
>> Yeah, yeah,
I love what everyone's been saying.
So let me see if I can say something
that's a little [LAUGH] different since
it's all such kind of good reflection
on the experience at Stanford, I think.
I was thinking about this and I was like,
what am I as a female leader?
And I think I immediately thought
of a class I took at spring
quarter of my second year
called Acting With Power.
And the class is kind of taught
kind of both with a professor and
with a woman who has more
of an acting background.
And the thinking and it's so strange
to take an acting class at the GSB and
it's not like that.
I especially had no talent and
like dreaded getting up in front
of class to act out scenes.
But the thinking is really, how can you
experiment with different behaviors and
saying different things and
inhabiting different characters to
kind of figure out what works for you.
So, there's something about that, I think,
post-GSB that's really empowered
me to feel like, listen,
if something isn't working,
I can try something else, and that's okay.
I've been in situations, healthcare can
be a really old school industry, and
I've been in situations where men just
have really overpowering attitudes and
are kind of talking over
each other in meetings.
And I feel like I can experiment I can be,
okay, I can try to match that,
and see if I get a response.
And if I don't get a response,
I can try something else.
And I feel like that was really empowering
to realize that I could adopt this kind of
curious mindset of experimentation to
figure out kind of what resonated.
I think the other part of it is
honestly getting to just meet
your classmates who are just so
incredible and talented and
[LAUGH] honestly intimidating in so
many ways.
And I feel like I've had so many text
messages and conversations with friends,
post-GSB, about, I've been in this
situation it made me feel a little weird
or I'm facing this challenge at work,
how would you handle it?
And these are friendships that
are deeply personal friendships, right?
We go on vacation [LAUGH] together,
we do other things together, but
it's really lovely to feel
like you can also have really
deep meaningful conversations
about your career and leadership,
in addition to all of the other
personal things that you care about.
>> Awesome, thank you.
Araeba, if there's anything else to add,
feel free.
>> I think we covered most bases but
I will plus one what Sithara just
said about having those people
who you meet at the GSB,
who keep you honest,
friends who keep you honest.
I think as I approach my career and
my role and get used to working
with a lot of folks who come
from very different backgrounds,
it's nice to still have those people
in your life who know all of you.
Yeah, just folks who you can talk to
about things that are coming up that
it's not always appropriate
to talk about at work.
What I'm thinking about is I will spend
a lot of time working with people
who don't necessarily look like me.
I work with a lot of white
male engineers every day.
I talk to, maybe,
one woman for every four men.
[LAUGH] And so, it's really nice to
have my lovely group of mostly female,
GSB besties to text and talk to.
And I just kind of describe
how I'm really feeling.
Which you don't always have
the luxury of doing that at work.
And having people who know you
at this deep visceral level, and
who live within spitting distance of you
in San Francisco, it's such a luxury and
it allows me to kind of compartmentalize
in other aspects of my career and life.
I think the other thing
I was going to say is,
not necessarily related
to just being female, but
the GSB did teach me that people
are people no matter what industry or
role or geography they're in.
I think as an immigrant I already sort of
knew this, at some level that my friends
back home and
my friends here they have a lot in common.
And a lot, you can build relationships and
build strong connections with anyone
regardless of their background.
And I think I'm more cognizant about
approaching folks who are much more
senior than me, or approaching folks
with very different skill sets or
backgrounds than me.
And knowing that I can build a connection
with them and I can have rapport with
them, and influence them,
and have them influence me.
I think that was something that I realized
at the GSB with the help of classes like,
what is proverbially called Touchy Feely,
but
it's officially called
Interpersonal Dynamics.
There's a lot of classes on interpersonal
dynamics beyond just Touchy Feely.
But I think just being able to understand
what motivates someone, what moves them,
how to communicate with them,
how to build a relationship with them,
regardless of whether they look like me or
not.
That was really empowering to me because,
I think, before the GSB I always sought
out sponsors and mentors who were also
women or who were also people of color.
And I am still going to keep doing that,
but just by virtue of the space I work in,
there aren't that many of those and I'm
going to need everyone in my wheelhouse.
And so building the confidence to build
relationships with everyone around me,
I think I got a lot of that at the GSB.
>> Awesome, thank you.
I'm going to ask the next question and I'm
going to just direct it to two of you, but
by all means, just for
sake of time so that we can try to get
through as many questions as possible.
But if someone wants to say something,
by all means, speak up.
So, this one is actually I'm going to
start with Tamar because it's directed
towards a point that you made
about just how you chose the GSB.
And the question is what was the final
differentiator that made you
choose the GSB?
And I want to make sure we just focus on
the GSB because none of us then ended up
attending other universities.
[LAUGH] So
we can't speak specifically to that.
But just, maybe, what was your thought
process as you were making your decision
and that might help people considering the
GSB as a place to apply but also one day,
hopefully attempt?
So ask Tamar and then, maybe,
Sithara, you can also, and
we'll have both of you chime in on this.
Yeah, definitely.
It was a really difficult decision for
me because I really wanted to be
international, and I talked a little bit
about the fact that I could have done
dual degree at the other
school that I was choosing.
But I think what made me choose
the GSB was that honestly it scared me
a little bit more, there was this
focus on, interpersonal dynamics, and
getting deep with people.
I had lived in the bay for a long time and
had heard of venture capital but
had no idea what that actually meant.
And so, I felt the GSB would push me out
of my comfort zone in a way that if I went
to any other school I might not have
to be pushed out of my comfort zone,
I could really easily retreat.
And so, I wanted to scare myself a little
bit, and so that's why I chose GSB.
>> Great, thanks for sharing.
Sithara, I'm curious to hear,
you can answer the same question
why you choose the GSB.
>> Yeah, it's actually it's interesting,
it's a little similar.
When I was trying to decide,
I went to weekend at the GSB,
and to be honest, I didn't love it.
I didn't walk away being, my gosh, this
place is amazing, I'm in love with it,
I have to go here.
I walked away and maybe I'm too
much of a total Midwesterner,
where I don't like talking about my
feelings with people I've just met,
I'm like,
why are you asking me about this?
We need to chit chat about the weather for
a couple of months
before we can get there.
And I feel there's so
much emphasis on the, of course,
everyone at the GSB says
the touchy feely part of it.
And then kind of intangibles, and
I feel, especially, coming from
a nonprofit background, I feel like I
want to learn about business, right?
I care about the academics.
And then I thought about it and I was,
you literally wrote your GSB essay
about taking on uncomfortable
experiences and seeking those out.
So, isn't it interesting that this
makes you feel uncomfortable, and
isn't that a sign that
there's a lot to learn here?
So, that's actually kind of what
ended up making the decision.
And I have to say,
I walked into day one of the GSB being,
I don't know if I'm going to this,
but I'll learn a lot and
then I'll have it on my resume,
and that's fine.
And now I kind of laugh at how I think
about it because it ended up being
such a rewarding experience and
so much more than that.
>> All right, thank you so much for-
>> I'd love to just add a really quick
other reason.
For me,
a lot of it to do with program size.
So I came from an undergraduate
experience, it was very small,
was all residential on campus,
I loved that.
And the other MBA programme I was looking
at had maybe 1000 or more students.
And the size of the GSB programme was
really attractive to me because you have
an opportunity to really get
to know all your classmates.
I know literally all of my classmates, and
that is really pays dividends and being
able to build relationships and having
a network that is really, really strong.
And then also just have more of
an opportunity to meet professors,
meet administrators.
There's just sort of fewer
people up in the mix, and so
you just have more opportunities.
>> That's a great point, and if there's
anything else anyone else wants to add,
please feel free.
I do want to call out, so
far I've mentioned admin weekend, and
those of you on the call today
are thinking about applying, right?
We have a September deadline, we have
a January deadline for round one and
round two.
Both of those rounds do
have an admin weekend.
So if you apply in those rounds and you
are accepted, I mean, you have the chance
then to, hopefully, by the time you
are admitted it might be in person,
it might be hybrid,
some of it might be online.
But you will have a chance to really
get to know students, and alumni, and
faculty, and get a sense of
what life is like at the GSB.
And that is specific to rounds one and
round two.
So as you're thinking through
what rounds to apply in,
that's just something to be aware of.
The next most up voted question is,
how did your time at Stanford
prepare you to switch industries?
And as I look at this slide that
I'm sharing with all of you,
I think almost all of you
did switch industries, and
even Tamer who might be in the same
technology and media switched roles.
So that's just really interesting
to highlight in general.
That's not always the case, some people do
returned to the same industry that they
were in after business school but
also many do use it as a chance to pivot.
So, I will choose Anneke and Areeba,
maybe to start answering this one.
I know Heather you already shared
your kind of your journey into
entrepreneurship.
So,
>> Yeah, entrepreneurship,
particularly in the technology
space was very interesting to me.
So I truly don't think you can find
a better program than Stanford's,
if that's what you want to do.
You are literally there in Silicon Valley,
the access to understanding
the funding ecosystem for startups,
the ecosystem for finding co founders.
And then all of the skill
sets that you need,
which are not necessarily the ones
you think you're going to need.
I found the curriculum was a really,
really good fit for that.
And it was something that I specifically
asked when I was talking to other
programs.
And several other programs literally their
line was we're just as good as Stanford at
helping you with entrepreneurship.
Which just was a clear sign to me that
Stanford was the leader in this category,
and that was very much my experience.
I think very similar to the path that
Heather went through of just being
able to have access to different
programs and curriculum,
and just being sort of in the soup of
startup world and entrepreneurship.
I think also just this
line about change lives,
change organizations, change the world.
Sounds a little cheesy sometimes, but
it's really true, I felt that in probably
my last week or two on campus when
we had different speakers and
events that were sort of putting
an end cap on our time at Stanford.
And it really stood out how much of
the experience was about go forth and
create something.
And that doesn't necessarily
have to be entrepreneurship,
you can do that in other ways.
But this idea of having
not only the skills,
but also the little fire
inside yourself to go and
make something in this world was so
much about that experience,
and I think Stanford is just
very unique on that front.
>> Great, thanks for sharing.
And, Areeba, if you want to share,
you already highlighted a little bit
about just how the GSB was integral and
you kind of heading to Apple, but in terms
of switching industries, how did it help?
>> Yeah, I will paraphrase this with,
I am an international student and
for those who are on the call and
are international,
you know that it's just an added
kind of stressor because.
I like to joke that I'm only ever in the
States because someone wants me to go to
their school or someone wants
me to work for their company.
And I in my head very much see the States
is where I've grown up, I'm 29,
I've been here since I was 19.
But definitely, I'm in a visa, and so,
for me going into the GSB, I think,
a lot of people take time to settle in and
take a few months and get to know people.
For me, personally,
I support my family and needed a visa, and
it started with thinking
about career from, I think,
before I came into the GSB and
had a long to-do list.
And I think what was helpful for
me and in getting through that list of
stressful things to-do was the classmates
who were already at the GSB.
And so, technically, you don't start
doing resume drops and career events and
whatnot until November, but I think even
just in the summer before the GSB and
August, September, October.
I reached out to folks in my class who
were working in product rolls across
small, big,
medium companies that I was interested in.
I was mostly looking at product and
big tech and FinTech.
And instead of just going directly to
potential employers or going to alumni, I
just reached out to people in my class and
the class above me, and that was really
helpful because it was Less stressful and
I was trying to build rapport.
Who am I talking to?
Who kind of reminds me of me?
Who would I emulate?
What company do they work at?
I feel like, I'd like working there,
because I like them, and
I sound like them.
Where should I apply,
and who do I talk to?
What are some friendly
faces at these places,
who are not just the resume drop order?
And then what can I say I have to offer,
what's my narrative?
What's my pitch?
And being able to really refine that
with classmates was super valuable.
And when it came time to actually go to
networking events, and do resume drops and
do interviews, just having all
that practice was super helpful.
Not to say everyone should start thinking
about their careers as soon as they get
into business school.
Take the summer off,
take some time off, but for
the international students on this call,
I hear you, it's stressful.
You have to kind of, you've added stress
and I think just leveraging the classmates
that you have even just at the GSB even,
outside of the amazing alumni network.
The folks that you're surrounded
with in the classroom and
that you're about you
are a big place to start.
>> Awesome, thank you for sharing.
The next question I might
pose to all of you, but
we'll start with Heather since she
didn't answer for the last one.
But could you just share a favorite moment
you've seen of women supporting women?
It could be during your time at the GSB or
your time after, also.
>> Gosh, yeah.
And I'll share two quickly.
One is that I have a really close
group of girlfriends from the GSB.
We have a very active group message
that probably people write in
it every single day, and
we Zoom every other week.
And we've been there for each other
through pregnancies and jobs switches,
promotions, parents getting ill,
all kinds of life events.
And so, I think, just like people
have said, having this really small,
close set of friends that you feel
you know everything about them and
they know everything about you.
That support really continues on.
The second is a fun note and
it's going to sound, Tamar you feature so
heavily in my life.
So we when we did our
first photo shoot for
Frankly we use a bunch of
models from our class at GSB.
So, Tamar was one of the models for
Frankly's first ever photo shoot.
And the same thing,
when we ran a kick starter last fall,
that was kind of how we
started the business.
And the women's channel
on our Slack blew up,
people were following it all day,
we got so many text messages.
So, I think the women in our
class really came together and
supported [LAUGH] what Jane and I were
trying to do, and are still trying to do.
So, that has been really fun and
uplifting.
It was people that I knew really well and
that I loved, but
also people that I didn't know,
as well, from school who came out and
were like this is what I'm thinking of,
or, I just had a baby and now I'm thinking
about how I can breastfeed and
not wearing a bra would be great for that.
So people have been so
helpful in directing ideas our way and
just supporting us in every way they can.
Tagging us in comments when Mina Harris
posts about not wearing a bra,
all kinds of stuff, so.
>> Awesome, thanks for sharing.
Tamar, do you want to add
anything to that, specifically?
>> Yeah, that's definitely the first
moment that I thought of, Heather,
because that was so fun.
A bunch of GSB girls got together in LA
and Heather and Jane were so professional,
I must say.
There was a makeup artist,
there was a professional photographer.
It was so fun.
Another moment that I have is,
I took this class called Paths to Power,
which is a little bit
similar to Acting with Power.
There's lots of classes about
power at Stanford, which are fun.
But this is all about, I think like,
engaging in power in a way that
a lot of people find uncomfortable.
But learning what the tactics are so
that you can understand how you can do it
yourself, but also how people are engaging
with power around you in a way
that you might not have noticed.
And, afterward, my friend Marta, and I,
and my class, created sort of like a group
of women who would try to do
powerful things together for
the spring quarter,
the class happens in the winter.
And we called it Power Posse.
And it was actually so fun and
we still have our WhatsApp
group to help each other.
And I think it's like, okay,
I want to write a medium post.
Should I post it?
And we're all sort of like, rah,
rah, you go, you should do this.
And so, I think that's one way that I'm so
engaged with women supporting women,
after the GSB.
>> Awesome, thanks.
Anneke, do you want to add to that?
>> Yeah, just both Heather and
Tamar referenced Slack channels,
WhatsApp groups, and
I have to just plus one that.
I think just to have powerful
amazing women on speed dial,
in my pocket that I can text them, and
know that I have someone who can help me
prepare to negotiate an elegant M&A deal.
Or help me debug my SQL query or advise me
on how to have a difficult conversation
at work, or
have a gynecologist recommendation.
All of those things,
I can get from the same people.
And it's just like, when people talk about
the network, to have a network of also
really powerful women,
just is like an extra awesome thing.
>> That's awesome.
Sithara, anything else to add to that,
a time when you've seen
women supporting women?
>> Yeah, I'm 100% on the WhatsApp threads.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I literally was just texting women's
GSB throughout a question earlier today,
so, it's a real thing.
I just think about like a month or two
ago, I was like having a hard time at work
and was meeting a friend of mine just
to get a manicure in San Francisco and
was talking to her.
And just ended up just like, totally
surprised me just like crying while we're
getting a manicure in this nail salon.
And my friend who was my GSB roommate,
who kind of runs her own company and
who I really kind of look up to,
professionally,
and think is a total badass,
just was like, it's okay Sithara.
She was like,
whenever I cry on a Zoom call or
something like that over the last year,
I've just been telling myself that
it's good to have an executive
cry every now and then.
[LAUGH] And
it was just such a funny moment of,
it had never occurred to me that,
one, she would even do that.
And it was just such a good moment
to be like, I feel so seen and
I feel okay just like sobbing in
a nail salon right now and it's fine.
[LAUGH] So,
just one moment of kind of many like that.
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> That's authentic vulnerability,
sharing that vulnerability.
It's actually really great.
>> Yeah, thank you for sharing that.
Areeba, anything else to add time and
women were supporting women
that you want to share?
>> I think you guys
covered a lot of bases.
I don't have anything super substantive.
So I'll give you that time back.
>> Great, so, another upvoted question.
So, from your experiences,
would you say the culture at Stanford
is more collaborative or competitive?
I think I know what you guys might answer,
but, it'd be great to
maybe share an example based on what
your answer is to that question.
So, Areeba,
why don't we go the other way now since
you didn't answer that other one?
>> Yeah, there is zero doubt in my
mind about the answer to this one.
It is 100% collaborative.
I was talking to someone the other day,
a mentor outside of the GSB who
said that he was struck by how I
thought about progress not as zero sum,
but as something that happens
concurrently for many people, at once.
And I was like, yeah,
I got that at the GSB.
Everyone is just so
willing to help everyone else, and
it's very much kind of
an attitude of your class.
I think it's an example, I think just,
if you're organizing an event, for
instance, I headed the deck club but
I was at the GSB with five other amazing
classmates and Every time we bring
an awesome speaker to campus,
for instance, if you're bringing
the head of the Senior PM for
iPhone to campus, like Astec Club,
you would reach out to product club.
And also, I don't know, like design club
and try to get them to come together so
that you can get as many classmates
as possible to attend this
awesome discussion.
There is no competition for
tech club to do an event and
eke out another club, it would truly
not even occur to anyone to do that.
So anytime you're doing something that
might be interesting to another classmate
or another organization on campus,
you move them in.
I think it's very similar from
a career point of view, I've never
really had a classmate who I reached
out to, and not respond to an email.
So even when you're in MBA 1, MBA 2s,
I think right at the beginning, feel and
accessible, and
just seem to have all of the wisdom, and
you're trying to figure it out,
like how they got so cool.
And I think a lot of reservations
reaching out to people and saying, hey,
I'm an MBA 1 and that overeager person
who's already thinking about interviewing.
Could you please talk to me
about your cool internship, and
everyone always responds even if they
don't have time to meet with you.
They're super busy, they're not in the
country, they'll support you by email or
Slack or WebEx or Zoom.
Yeah, people are super,
super collaborative.
I think another example
is just interview prep.
Even if you're applying for the same jobs,
because a lot of people apply to Google
and Apple and the bigger companies,
I prepped for interviews together.
I let my classmates know, hey,
I moved to the next round, and
this is someone I talked to who was super
helpful, do you also want to talk to them?
You make introductions for books at your
old company or the company you enjoy that.
It's just very much kind of
in the DNA of the school.
And whether you go to the GSB or not,
I would just advocate for all of us as
women, just seeing progress is something
that happens concurrently for all of us.
And I think sometimes, especially in
places where there aren't enough women in
leadership, there can be the attitude of
I want to be the only woman in power, and
I didn't see any of that at the GSB.
And hopefully there will be none of
that on this panel of 108 people either.
>> [LAUGH] Thank you.
I don't think we have time to get to
everyone because we just have a few
minutes left.
But I'd love to ask Anneke, just going in
reverse order again, to chime in if you
have anything else to add about
collaborative versus competitive?
>> I think that point on competing for
jobs was a good one.
And it made me think of a couple
of real concrete examples.
Something I see a lot on threads
with GSBers is people who have
the job position for their boss is open,
and they'll blast it out to GSB folks or
pick specific ones and say, hey,
I'd love for you to interview for
this job to come and be my boss.
Or in places where, I've definitely
had friends who went through
an interview process, didn't get the job,
but then reached out to me and said,
I think you might be better for this job,
here's all the information for it.
So that's sort of job sharing, and
trying to help lift people up,
you see all the time.
>> Awesome, is there anything else
that any of you would like to add in
terms of just talking about the culture,
and
a time maybe that the collaborative
nature of the program was notable to you?
>> And
I just want to say something really fast.
And I think that the nature
of the program is so
collaborative that you will serve yourself
the best if you come to Stanford by
telling everybody what
you're interested in or what
you're passionate about because people
will bring that back to you tenfold.
If they know what you care about,
anytime there's an opportunity or
something that even marginally relates to
it, or if they're thinking about it or
talking to someone,
they will point that person back to you.
And that has been one of the most
powerful things that I got out of
the Stanford network.
It's just people's understanding
of what I cared about and
willingness to connect me to the things
that would make sense for that.
>> Awesome, thanks for sharing.
I'm actually going to flip to the next
slide, and I feel like that's a really
nice note to end on because you talked
about kind of bringing yourself and
knowing your interests and
being willing to share that with people.
And I think as you start to hone
in on that as you go through our
application process.
And we ask some big questions,
we're still asking the same question
that all of our panelists had to answer,
what matters most to you and why Stanford?
So I encourage all of you to continue
your journey online with us.
We have a lot of resources up there in
addition to being able to track your
application, you can also learn
more about courses and clubs.
There are other events offered in the next
few weeks prior to the round one deadline.
So I also encourage you to check our event
page if you're interested in attending
another panel such as this one.
We have regular information sessions, and
we do have some just in
time webinars coming up.
We call those just in time, meaning, they
are right before the round one deadline.
So if you are stuck on something in
your application and need advice or
guidance from the admissions team and
we are here for you through that process.
So I encourage you to sign up for those.
Also, I want to thank our panelists.
Thank you, all of you for
joining us today.
Thank you for your time.
I know many of you are calling in
from work, we just put up a poll, so
please let us know your
feedback on this event.
And again, I know everyone is
calling in from all over the world.
So I hope that everyone has a good
rest of their day, afternoon, morning,
evening, whatever it is, wherever you are.
Thank you so much again for
your time today to everyone.
[MUSIC]